Stephanie pomboy is an economist she
founded macro mavens where she is the
CEO she joins us tonight Stephanie
thanks so much for coming on so can you
just give us your coolest most attached
assessment of what we're seeing this
seems like a big deal is it
well I mean I can't believe that you're
not alade by listening to treasury
secretary Yellen I mean clearly she's
got the situation in hand I also am just
done Tucker that you don't believe that
diversity equity and inclusion are the
root of a sound financial system I mean
come on where have you been for the last
year Tucker It's time for the kids to be
quiet and like let's get some real
economists here who aren't just like
repeating Atlantic articles this is
insane
it is absolutely insane and and the
layers of insanity I mean I can't even
believe the videos you showed about the
the people at SF svb you know uh focused
on the women's ski vacations and whatnot
it's just nonsense and you're right what
we're facing right now is really serious
I mean we are on the brink of a 2008
style financial crisis and I'm not
trying to be hyperbolic in fact you and
I discussed this at length in our
long-form interview several months ago
um and at the time the FED hadn't even
raised rates nearly as high as they have
today and I was saying look you don't
raise rates in record Fashion on an
economy toning record leverage at
maximum speculation and expect no
consequence I mean this was clearly
going to happen and now we're seeing the
weak links in the Chain break you know
the areas where speculation was most
rampant and most egregious are clearly
coming down and they're doing so as they
seem to do in all the three-letter
acronyms just like they did in 2008 you
know we're back to the three letter
acronyms
um and there'll be a lot more of those
and and frankly I think you know this is
the unintended consequence of the fed's
monetary policy uh layered with really
bad fiscal policy on top of it but
essentially they've been encouraging
people to take Reckless risks for years
just because you had no alternative you
could get zero percent sitting in a
t-bill or having your money in the bank
or you could run out and you could
speculate
um and that's what they've done and
that's all coming back to bite them hard
and we've got some major consequences
coming at us and I think it's going to
devolve very rapidly because of all the
leverage that's been built up here it's
exactly right if you treated your
children like the FED is treated Wall
Street your kids would all be in rehab
you know and what they've done is bad um
no doubt Stephanie Palm boy I appreciate
your wisdom on this thank you
thank you Tucker pleasure subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight